I wrote an open letter in Polestar this
year which is like the Touring magazine
and I had just had this situation where
for the first time I got my wife who's
pregnant with another little girl and
I'm like thinking I'm seeing how
different my wife's experience is to
mine just like very very drastically
well thank you for paying attention
completely different yeah so then I'm
thinking about that on tour and like
Mandy I've never just asked the women on
my tour like what can I do differently
for you on this tour so I got them all
together a room and I was just like hey
is there anything different I can do is
there is there anything different for
women that I can do to make this better
and I'm not thinking I'm yeah and they
gave me a couple things that could be
done better one of them was uh
trash cans on the tour bus with lids
yeah because I just like would never
have thought of that yeah but just you
know like you know sometimes we have a
certain time of month and you want a lid
on the track yeah yeah and I never knew
it like that would have never crossed my
mind yeah well you don't exactly go
around and they each share something
that could be helpful and then they each
went around and said like no one's ever
asked me this before
yeah I'm just like what no one's ever
asked you this before that's insane you
guys have all been touring forever how's
this not happened and then I'm like
looking back at myself I've been touring
for eight years I've never asked you
this before yeah what the hell is going
on why what's the disconnect like I
think I'm a good guy and I've never
asked you this before so then I'm like
man I got to share this and I wrote this
open letter and tried to share it in the
touring community you know my mom was an
amazing woman who helped to try to
empower as many women as possible and
she would always like read this quote to
me about that the world of humanity is
like has two wings male and female and
unless they're both strong like the bird
can't fly so it's correct it's like not
revolutionary but the ID when men stick
up for women with like a pure intent it
just like makes me emotional but it's
like really important and there's not
enough of it and why you're getting
emotional is because you now have your
oh yeah I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this